joining me now is chris montana who owns
dunaward craft spirits in minneapolis
and bill anderson owner of dale's diner
in dale's bar and grill in ohio welcome
to both of you
pleasure to be here chris we're moving
to a critical stage in the derek chauvin
trial in minneapolis i know your
business was damaged last summer and the
riots following george floyd's death
how concerned are you about more trouble
in your city
i mean i'm concerned i think we all are
the city's on edge
i don't know that the the the outcome of
the
trial one way or the other is gonna do
much as far as healing is concerned but
our hope at this point is that uh people
keep their cool and let the process play
out and to the extent that
there are protests we've been supportive
in the past and i suspect we will be in
the future
bill my understanding is you've
struggled to find folks to work in your
diner
our enhanced unemployment benefits
keeping folks on the couch
instead of peeling potatoes busting
tables and refilling customer coffees
that's exactly right mike it's been bad
for the last several months
to try to hire we're down a couple of
cooks my wife and i were in the kitchen
cooking and it just
i knew it was going to keep going until
unemployment ended
probably at the end of september so it
was kind of an unsustainable situation
for us
and um we needed to hire people and
usually we put ads out on different
medias and and we get you know 10 to 12
apps and we
choose the best one and something
changed
something changed all of a sudden like
three months ago and
we put we put ads out and we get no one
no one
so it's obvious that you know they're
staying home they're making more money
staying home
and uh it's just killing our business
it's killing
thousands of businesses all around the
all around the country
bill let me follow up with you uh real
fast on that so what's your message to
lawmakers here in washington
hey it's it's pretty simple um
all right we got a lot of businesses out
in this country that are ready to open
fo go ready to hire people and you guys
the government is hijacking our
workforce
period amen they're hijacking our
workforce
we cannot hire people because they're
paying more to stay home
and i'm not blaming the people trust me
i mean
getting free money is kind of cool i i
mean i i gotta admit it would be fun
but it's not sustainable and it's not
right okay
the government needs to just stop paying
this extra 300 or
500 or whatever it is and making it you
know impossible for us to hire
chris so anyway consequently our diner
closed
and i've i'm seeing bars and restaurants
all over toledo area
closing reduced hours i mean all but
all factors all all sectors of the the
economy are being affected
it's not just the bars and restaurants
and breweries i mean everybody's being
affected here
i got a friend who's got a foundry and
he can't hire people at 30 to 35 dollars
an hour
wow chris i've been interviewing small
business owners every sunday this year
hearing their stories about dealing with
covid for more than a year
uh when you combine covid with the
unrest in minneapolis
um what's it been like trying to survive
as a business owner
i feel like i've run maybe three or four
different businesses in the past year
and a half
you certainly have to be adaptable and
i've watched a number of
my friends lose their businesses it's
been tough
but you know i feel like there is some
light at the end of the tunnel here and
you know we haven't had as much
difficulty bringing people back i think
one of the
the critical points is when people work
with you and they feel respected in your
space and you pay them a
proper wage we found that people are
happy to come back in and and so
our staff's ready to go and when they
feel like it's safe we're going to
reopen our bar but we're still producing
our distillery still working and so
i i think the i think the future is
going to be good i think we just need to
get
past this last little bit with code
we're nearly out of time chris you want
to give a shout out to some of your
loyal customers for
being loyal to your business yeah
you know customers and community i mean
we're we're a tiny little business in
many ways we shouldn't still be here
we were massively under capitalized but
our community supported us that's why we
support them
and i i thank everyone who has helped us
out through some really tough times this
past year and a half
bill what about you and your customers
you want to give them some praise for
being loyal to you we've had a great run
ten years at dale's diner i've got 33
years at dale's bar and grill that's
still going strong it's still open and
running
to dale's diner customers hang in there
we're going to we're going to try to
open this thing up again
so so just hang in there we'll be back
chris montana bill anderson gentlemen
thanks so much our best to you
your families and your staff thanks mike
thanks for having us